i had to bring back the sunglasses for
this one
[Music]
extremis extremis
i'm going with extremists oh
coming off the back of oxygen another
really
really good episode this is another one
again
much like oxygen where the more i think
about it
the more i pick it apart and examine it
the stronger it becomes
it's funny there are plenty of things
out there not just doctor who plenty of
pieces of entertainment out there that
when you start sorting through it and
picking at it and pulling up
threads it kind of falls apart doesn't
mean they're bad it just means that like
maybe the
fun was papering over stuff that was
like
uh don't notice this and if it did its
job well then you didn't notice but then
you go back and look more closely like
oh right
then there are other things where you
start to you start to pick at it and you
realize oh
this is way more tightly knit than i
thought it was
wow and extremist kind of has that going
on
which i'm always happy to find if i can
so this is the one that open
well first of all we have holdover from
the last one the doctor
is still blind i love that
i love that there were lasting
consequences to the event of oxygen just
on principle
i love that and i also love the way that
they deal with it
i love that the doctor is using the
sonic specs
to as a workaround but it's a deeply
flawed and imperfect workaround
it's played for humor at a couple points
but it also becomes a logistical hurdle
along the way
and it's super respectful
i think in a way that sci-fi often isn't
to the nature of trying to deal with a
disability because
oftentimes when you're dealing with
fantasy or science fiction
when somebody has a disability they have
they end up having some sort of ability
remedy piece of
tech whatever that effectively
eliminates the problem
in like maybe it's a little bit
different than if they still had the
natural
ability that most people do but for the
most part they can function as if they
did
you know think jordy laforge or any
cybernetic
limb on any number of characters from
any freaking anime
or sci-fi thing ever here
this is much more reminiscent of what is
actually like
to try and compensate for just well
to my understanding i get able-bodied
person if i am
getting this wrong i'm sure someone will
correct me but at least to my
understanding of it which is that
you can't just replace the thing you
lost with something that does the exact
same thing
if you're lucky you can replace it with
something that does
kind of the same thing but like it's
gonna come up short in a lot of areas
the ways in which you know
a prosthetic limb or being confined to a
wheelchair yeah you can still move
around
but it's not like you still have use of
your legs
so the fact that it can give him it can
give him the outlie
the uh outline and the shape of a room
it can identify people it can give him
information about those people
age height you know all this stuff
but he can't read a book because he
can't do
text it's basically like sonar in a way
it's still very limited and there's a
bunch of information he's not
getting and he has to try and work
around that
so i like that for you know again
lasting consequences but it just
feels like a more respectful way to try
and depict
someone compensating for loss of
function
in some area so moving on from that this
this thing
it has a book end uh well i say bookend
it pops up across it as it goes along
in a way that doesn't completely cleanly
integrate i'd actually forgot that this
was the episode where we establish
what happened with missy and that it is
missy and the vault i'd forgotten that
this was that same episode
largely because it doesn't
intermix with the primary story
it doesn't it doesn't interfere with it
either but it doesn't complement it i
feel like that
aspect of the story is in this episode
because
this was about the point in the series
where they had to get it in there
so they just found a way to get it in
and just tried to have it not
interrupt the the other story
as as much as possible and honestly i do
think they pulled that off but i would
have really liked if they could have
found a way
or a point at which to bring in this
information about
missy and have it flow more organically
into the concepts or the themes of
the primary story being told and that
doesn't really happen here that said in
isolation
the stuff uh is still really good like i
love this whole concept
of these people who their whole thing
is knowing how to kill every single kind
of sentient life in the universe
and that they take a ton of pride in
this that they have all this information
on how to kill
anything like that's just a cool concept
and oftentimes when i say that about
something that's very much a side thing
and doctor who i find myself going
i kind of wish there was more that they
done with it honestly i'm not sure
there's more that you could have done
with that
other than this i feel like this is
actually the perfect amount of time to
to be with people that where that's your
concept they
they are basically executioners for hire
because they can kill anything
not like in a mercenary badass way just
uh oh you have captured something that
you need kill
okay we we can tell you how to do it uh
sort of way
and i i don't think there was more that
you could or needed to milk out of that
concept so that works really well
i think i'm gonna like address that
whole thing here so i don't have to
circle back to it at the end even though
in the episode it does come back at the
end which
that's the one thing where i will say is
slight not disruptive
but loses momentum because the climax of
the episode
overall is very much very strongly
the doctor emailing himself
and getting the information and then you
know we have a natural sort of
wrap up in denumal to to sound really
pretentious
um with bill you know establishing
the real bill and and all of that but
then it keeps going because we have to
pick up
on missy and establish firmly that she's
not dead and she's in the vault and the
doctor has watched her for a thousand
years
some of which i'm not sure needed to be
firmly established like they
they set up this whole thing so the
doctor can say like i'm going to watch
her body that turns out the body's not
dead but like
hadn't we pretty cleanly already
established that whatever was in the
vault was alive
i mean it had knocked back the doctor
had had a one-sided
admittedly conversation with it i think
we kind of knew
something was alive in there so i don't
know why they try and play that like
it's a twist
or a surprise that she's not dead i
don't know
but again like that stuff in isolation
for the most part works it's solid but
let's get
let's get to the meat of it so
the initial concept the initial idea
of this one truth
about the world that anyone who learns
it
commits suicide first off
that's a killer hook i mean it's it's
borderline lovecraftian
that idea of like the truth will drive
you mad
so i i just i love that vibe secondly
that's the kind of setup that is almost
impossible to pay off satisfactorily
it's the kind of premise and starting
question that you're like
ooh i can't wait to find out the answer
and the answer is almost
always a disappointment it doesn't quite
live up to what it should have been
i think this answer is perfect for that
setup though
especially the way that they play it and
the way that it gets
revealed and the here's the big thing
sticking with bill
because here's the thing if you watch
sci-fi
much sci-fi at all especially tv shows
you've seen plenty of times where
people who turn out to be
androids holograms mental projections
whatever
have this sort of moment of crisis of
wait are you saying i'm not real
and it almost never
lands the way it's intended to
because pretty much any time any other
show does it
those people are appearing only in the
episode that they're in or in the case
of the movie like we've only known him a
couple hours and
more it's it's virtually never the main
character it's not
our eyes it's not our point of view
character
now bill we've already gotten to know
across multiple episodes
and this thing sticks with her as the
reality of all this sinks in
and i love that it takes the time to
slow down it doesn't act
like oh rug pull it's a twist like no no
no no
we're gonna wait and see if you catch on
to this and then if you don't we'll lay
it out for you but even after we've laid
it out
there is that conversation in the white
house between the doctor
and bill and that is slow
that is thoughtful that is perfectly
pitched
because you can see all of it sinking on
her weighing on her this idea
but i have to be real and you feel the
pain of that
of that realization that she isn't
i felt that here way harder than i have
ever felt it in
any other thing i've ever seen pull the
oh my god am i real on a character
before
i've never seen it hit as hard as this
hits it
it's so well executed and like
it tracks like the more i think about it
like
once it's been proven to you once you
know and that number test is also
freaking brilliant once you know
it's true yeah
i would believe people would remove
themselves from the situation
because nothing else that they have ever
measured themselves by
no amount of personal success ambition
family
creative works nothing none of it
matters
so the only choice you can make that
matters
is to not play the game anymore and i
love
that the comparison is made to video
games repeatedly and early on
again like how tightly knit this this
thing is
so when the doctor first encounters the
monks
and he says this is not a game this is
good because i win and you think it's
metaphorical they're playing with him
they're trying
no literally this whole
thing is a game and that
that sort of white space place with the
with the portals that's basically the
hub world
where they can step into the different
levels that they've created
and like there's so much tension
when nardole puts his hand outside the
projectors and
realizes he's not real and he's
panicked at that and again the weight of
it on bill and having that carry over to
the next scene
like i said that setup of what's one
truth
that would have virtually every single
person on the planet
have ultimately the same reaction you
know maybe some people will kill
themselves immediately some people would
try and
you know do something you know to make
it more
momentous or like in the case of the one
person who translated the veritas you
know
get the word to other people before but
you know
ultimately would do that like yeah i'd
buy it
because if you know if you truly know
that you are not real whether that
hits you like a sledgehammer immediately
and you want out or whether you're
trying to hold on
and the weight of that fact drives you
down over time yeah
i do believe that everyone will make
that same decision ultimately if that
was true
if that was what happened this
is a very specific kind of horror that i
i don't know where else i've seen it but
like
this is the horror and the tragedy of
unreality i feel like in a lot of ways
this
episode is not as well remembered as it
should be
because like and maybe that's because it
feeds into the next two-parter which
tends to have a much more mixed reaction
but look honestly it sets that up
but this is a proper standalone story
and it's a really
really good one and i'd honestly forgot
that this was the origin point
for without hope without witness
without reward you do it
not because you have hope that it'll
work you do it
not because you're being watched by
people who will judge you
you do it you don't do it because you're
going to be rewarded you do it because
it's the right thing or because it's the
only thing you can do
and i love that that is introduced by
nardole i love that it is riversong's
words i love that it is what spurns the
doctr on to email himself i love that
the
that the monks basically cooked their
own goose by making a
digital version of the doctor that is
pretty much as clever as the doctors
like oops
that was a mistake you shouldn't have
done that i love the idea that the
doctor temporarily borrows eyesight
when doesn't know the price like he said
like maybe
maybe my next regeneration will be blind
maybe i won't be able to regenerate at
all maybe i'll drop dead
in 20 minutes i love this idea that he
is so intent on
finding out what this is that he's
prepared to basically
pull the lever on a random number
generated
generator for something that it's going
to cost him he doesn't know what it is
but he's like i'll pay it
i don't know what but i'll pay it like
that again the
tension involved in this there's also
some great lighter moments like i love
the establishing of
nardole is kind of a secret bad ass
while still being
the goofy kind of guy that nardole is
that's great stuff
also this is the this along with look me
up
from uh the force of the dead is about
the one other time that i
i it does work for me when the doctor
pulls on his own reputation
because it's not that these people
already know what he's capable of is
that once they look into him
it's like oh crap because it does bother
me when the doctors just like swaggers
in is like
you know who i am and you should all be
scared i'm like nah
that usually doesn't work for me so much
but here where he's like
look up the doctor's like we have an
entry for you he's like no under cause
of
death and again actually kind of tying
back to something i mentioned in the
thin ice review he's
owning the fact that
he has killed people way more
than the doctor usually has he's usually
much more evasive
about that you know in terms of just
flat out admitting
i am the cause of death not just that i
win that people lose when they stand up
against me
people die and again like it feeds back
into something done earlier this series
there's just a lot of recurring
awesome stuff that just keeps connecting
across this series
this this is not a lot to remind me
why i like series 10 so much i
really do love it and i feel really bad
because it seemed like a lot of people
didn't like for some for reasons that i
share others for reasons that i don't
who kind of like felt everything came
apart in series eight and nine and i
feel like a lot of people prejudged
series 10
assuming that while we've already had
two series under moffitt and capaldi i
know what it is and it's not going to be
any better than what it's already been
but it
is it's so good
you people i mean
ah extremists
love it you rewatched it lately what'd
you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about i have a patreon
it is what pays the bills keeps this
entire operation up and
running and there's also the usual stuff
you can do that all helps me out like
share subscribe i like comments
regardless because i do
really love engaging with you people but
you also don't have to do any of it
because
end of the day you're the council i just
run the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]